so I've talked about the gas lighting
that has been carried out either
deliberately or accidentally by the
current administration I told you that
in 2020 I'm going to do everything I can
to prevent the gas lighting from
attaching to society and I have to start
today by telling you that Donald Trump
is claiming that one of his greatest
honors was doing something that he just
didn't do something that was done five
almost six years ago that actually it
was Bernie Sanders and the late John
McCain and Barack Obama that did it the
thing this is so absurd that it is again
I find myself wanting to use that
language this is almost unreal but I
want to be careful because as I told you
I don't want to normalize this it sounds
unreal but it is not Donald Trump is
claiming that his greatest honor at the
end of 2019 he said was getting veterans
Choice approved choice was a bill by
Bernie Sanders and John McCain which
Barack Obama signed into law this is
stunning
but it's real and it's unacceptable
here's Donald Trump's tweet just four
hours before the end of 2019 quote one
of my greatest honors was to have gotten
choice approved for our great veterans
others have tried for decades and failed
the veterans Choice Act was signed into
law in 2014 by then President Barack
Obama here is a picture of Barack Obama
signing this into law
you see Bernie Sanders standing right
next to Barack Obama the bill was
sponsored by senators Bernie Sanders and
John McCain years ago Donald Trump did
not do this now does Donald Trump not
know that he didn't do this is if
they're liberal deliberately lying I
don't know why Donald Trump is saying
this is unclear now Donald Trump did
expand eligibility for veterans choice
you can say well that's a good thing and
that's fine but Donald Trump is lying or
clueless when he says that this has been
a failure for decades which he then was
able to accomplish what Trump did is
make some tweaks and they're fine tweaks
where veterans would be allowed to go to
private doctor's
the weight for a VA doctor is more than
20 days before Trump it was 30 days
Trump reduced it to 20 days that's great
Donald Trump changed the eligibility so
that veterans are allowed to see a
private doctor if the closest VA
facility is more than 30 minutes away
previously it was 40 miles these are
fine changes but they are merely tweaks
this is gas lighting or lying or
something Trump is the first to claim
credit for things that he didn't
actually do and will never take
responsibility for his blunders or his
failures it's like they don't exist this
is a very narcissistic way to lead but
it's working for Donald Trump and this
is where the challenge comes to us in
2020 the gas lighting works for Trump
people want to believe what Donald Trump
is telling them if they voted for him
because they want to feel justified
somewhere deep down they recognize their
vote for Trump was a blunder it was a
self-destructive Act it was an
embarrassing act on the national stage
so they are primed to take whatever
Trump says even if it's demonstrably
false like I accomplished veterans
choice no you didn't it was Bernie and
John McCain signed in by Barack Obama
five six years ago you didn't do it they
don't care they want to believe it and I
got an email from a veteran who said I
have a veterans Choice card in my wallet
I've had it for years
Trump didn't just do this the card says
2014 on it it says nothing about Trump
Trump was a reality host at the time
that I received a card for a program
that he is now trying to take credit for
we can say it's sad we can say it's
unreal or whatever but we can't let this
stuff become normalized this is like if
Bill Clinton had said I did the New Deal
no you didn't FDR did it 50 years ago
this is equally bonkers we can't let him
get away with it and unfortunately his
followers are in a state where they are
more than willing willing is not a
strong enough term they welcome
Trump get away with it because they want
to be convinced of this stuff maybe just
as much as Trump seems to have convinced
himself it's a very sad state of affairs
for the country we can at least start
trying to remedy it with voting to
remove Donald Trump in just 10 months
it's incredible we're just 10 months
from the election one of our sponsors is
privacy calm they're giving you $5.00
when you sign up for their completely
free service at privacy calm slash
Pakman I've been using privacy for a
little over a year now you've heard me
talk about it before it's a lifesaver
and here's how it works takes just a
couple of minutes to set up anytime you
buy something online or on the phone
instead of actually using your real
credit card number the privacy app and
the browser plugin let you give each
company a randomized virtual credit card
number that you create out of thin air
it'll even autofill the card number with
one click and the payment is taken out
of your checking account without the
merchant ever knowing your real
information so this allows you to keep
your banking information secure but also
to take control of your finances you can
create up to 12 of these virtual credit
cards a month you can set spending
limits you can freeze them you can
delete them any time you want so when
you do this it means you're not going to
be charged when you don't want to be
because you can destroy the virtual card
number right after using it which for
instance I love using free trials
because I know I won't be charged when
the trial is over if I use a virtual
credit card number you're keeping your
identity private by not telling
companies who you are you're keeping
your bank or credit card info protected
against data breaches and identity theft
and it's free there's no catch
whatsoever but if you want privacy also
offers a $10 a month plan that gives you
one percent cashback and lets you create
36 credit cards a month and a $25 a
month plan tailored more for small
businesses where you can create 60 card
numbers a month and much more
but definitely go ahead and at least get
started with a free plan you'll protect
your financial info companies can't
charge you unexpectedly and like I said
you'll get five dollars to spend
when you sign up at privacy calm /
Pakman